tomorrow night 48 hours explores the
aftermath of a young woman's murder and
the harassment of her grieving family
seventeen-year-old bianca devins was a
popular figure on social media bianca
was murdered in utica new york in 2019
her killer posted images of her body
online and they went viral the images
were also sent to bianca's family tarika
duncan spoke with the family in their
first national tv interview
in july 2019 the social media platform
discord was buzzing about a photo that
appeared to show a dead young woman so i
was reading all the messages and they're
like saying that bianca is dead at first
elizabeth wasn't too concerned about her
friend bianca devins and thought it
might be fake on discord it's fairly
common
for people to post gore and disturbing
images just to sort of get a rise out of
people reporter e.j dixon covered the
story for rolling stone magazine it was
certainly within the realm of
possibility that this could have been
faked dispatched to all units but it all
became very real when a 9-1-1 call came
in from brandon clark we have him on the
line now a young man that bianca had
been out with that night
40's on pole wearing body cameras utica
police detectives rushed to the location
after a brief struggle police disarmed
clark and placed him under arrest
investigators soon discovered bianca's
body under a tarp so you better send
somebody to the mom's house
to
give her a heads up but bianca's mother
kim devins already knew
someone had texted bianca's family the
horrific photo i just kept screaming
it's not her it's not her it's not my
baby in the days and weeks that followed
the images went viral on social media
and online trolls relentlessly sent
bianca's family the photos and cruel
memes behavioral scientist stephen
cremando so this is a collection of
different
communications received by bianca's mom
and obviously every one of them meant to
be incredibly cruel incredibly hurtful
this is a form of psychological
terrorism
yeah
now jerica you're with us again um what
can you tell us about who sent those
photos to her family so the behavioral
scientists that we spoke to stephen
cremando said that they believed that
this was the work of incels the question
is what is an incel an incel according
to him is someone that's part of a group
that's involuntary celibate essentially
these are men who
are loners um they are upset that they
don't get the attention from attractive
women right and that's the group that
cremando said was mainly responsible for
sending out these images now it's
important to note that brandon clark
himself
was not considered an incel but he was
definitely celebrated by that community
now what happened to brandon clark after
his arrest yeah so he was sentenced to
25 years to life charged with second
degree murder the family of course
though wants to stay on this because
he'll be 48 and a half years old when
he's up uh for consideration of her role
but again 25 to life what's his
motivation why would he the family wants
them to stay behind bars the prosecutors
say simply you know
bianca devin said
i don't want to be exclusive he couldn't
handle that and they say this is a case
of if nobody could have her you know
then i can't have you nobody exactly
unfortunately uh thank you so much now
you can see jericho's report the online
life and death of bianca devins on 48
hours tomorrow night at 10 9 central
here on cbs and on the viacom cbs
streaming service paramount plus